photo mh un bon soir alors joe biden
s'est exprimé que peut-on retenir de
cette conférence thomas
et bien c'était un discours qui a duré
une dizaine de minutes joe biden n'a
répondu à aucune question il s'agissait
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
de faire un point d'étape sur la
situation en ukraine selon joe biden il
ya toujours deux options sur la table et
les etats unis se tiennent prêts pour
ces deux options la première de ces
options c'est la voie diplomatique pour
résoudre cette crise les etats unis qui
seront également prêts à répondre en cas
d' attaques de la russie contre
l'ukraine voilà ce que déclare ce soir
joe biden le président américain qui est
également revenu sur son entretien du
week-end avec vladimir poutine le
président russe et moi sommes d'accord
pour poursuivre les discussions écouter
jo bagdad
hier le gouvernement russe a
publiquement proposé de continuer vers
la voie diplomatique
et je suis d'accord nous devons donner
toutes ses chances de succès à la
diplomatie
je pense qu'il existe une véritable
possibilité de respecter la sécurité de
chacun
joe biden qui affirme que les nations le
droit de choisir leur alliance et avec
qui elle s'associe il est également
revenu sur la situation autour de cette
frontière entre la russie et l'ukraine
il explique que les services de
renseignement américains ne sont pas en
mesure de vérifier les informations
selon lesquelles des militaires russes
quittent actuellement cette région
écouter les d'état est donné par joe
biden
le ministère russe de la défense a
annoncé aujourd'hui que certains
militaires russes doivent quitter leur
position aux abords de l'ukraine ce
serait une bonne chose mais nous n'avons
pas encore vérifié cette information
nous n'avons pas encore pu vérifier si
les militaires russes ont bien regagné
leurs bases
joe biden qui est également revenu sur
la décision de déplacer l'ambassade
américaine de kiev vers l'ouest de
l'ukraine où washington qui invite
toujours les ressortissants américains à
quitter le pays et puis le locataire de
la maison blanche s'est adressé
directement aux citoyens russes les
citoyens russes vous n'êtes pas nos
ennemis ne veux pas déstabiliser la
russie voilà ce qu'a déclaré joe biden
depuis la maison blanche le président
américain qui a également une nouvelle
fois agité la menace de sanctions des
sanctions puissante qui sont prêtes et
on comprend qu elles viseront notamment
le gazoduc north stream 2 qui n'entrera
pas en activité si la russie attaque le
crème voilà ce que déclare joe baida
nord ce discours intervient quelques
heures après un entretien téléphonique
entre sergueï lavrov et anthony blinken
un discours qui intervient aussi à la
veille de la date avancée par un certain
nombre de médias américains cette date
du 16 février qui selon des éléments des
services de renseignement qui américain
qui abreuvent les journalistes ici cette
date pourrait donc être le début de
l'offensive russe en ukraine selon les
médias américains
merci beaucoup thomas bonnin en direct
de washington